i'd like to remind members using devices
that you must
mute and turn off your sound to avoid
feedback
consider turning off your video if you
intend to use the keyboard for taking
notes
for good sound quality is it important
for members to speak clearly and be
mindful of the location of the
microphones
at the same time be aware that from most
parts of the room the microphones in the
room pick up
sound very well be careful about side
conversations
the committee room computer will be
muted at lunch break
a committee member will need to unmute
it before we resume after lunch
however today we won't be resuming after
lunch because our one o'clock
presentation has to be rescheduled
because the senate finance committee
called
the people who will be
making that presentation to speak on hb2
in the department of energy before
all right this is a pre-hearing
announcement
for attendees the sign up sheet will
stop accepting new
in entries for those who wish to speak
at 8 a.m the day of the committee's
hearing
this is not a committee hearing so
that's not really relevant
i won't finish the rest of that
pre-hearing announcement
instead as chair of the science
technology
energy committee i find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor is the result
of the covet 19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is good morning everybody
good morning this is a session uh
morning
session we can hear you
can you hear us
i'm not sure anyway this is a public
hearing on bills referred to the
or a work session rather on bills
referred to the committee
and scheduled in the house calendar for
today
we are not planning to do any executive
sessions today please note
that there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order
i confirm that all members of the
committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform the public
has
access to contemporaneously listened and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has begun
morning in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar
on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271-3600
ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
any votes taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
and we'll start by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also
state whether there is anyone in the
room with you during the meeting
that's required under the right to know
law so mr clerk
would you call the role yes mr chair uh
doug thomas is not present in the room
but i understand he's at a
chair vice chair meeting is that correct
and he's on his way
then i'll back him as a present
representative harrington here
representative notter
she's at the meeting she's where
she meets me uh representative murder
here
uh representative clint here uh
representative
berezni here in the committee room okay
and i have to wait for a second to list
hourglass shots off uh representative
bernardi
here in committee representative
cambrils
uh representative campbell's here in my
home in loudoun alone
okay represent president in committee
rep representative samsic i'm here
i'm miss representative white i'm here
in the committee representative samsich
yes i'm president here in portsmouth and
there's nobody else in the house with me
i saw you on the screen representative
i'll mark the president i saw her on the
screen represent a man
i'm here at home no one with me
representative lockstrom
present in playing field i'm alone in my
office but there are other people in the
house
okay representative mcwilliams
i'm present at my home with my family
representative creation i am here in my
home alone
and there's a lot of background noise
today sorry representative pimentel
here on my patio my sister
and wife may pass occasionally but
essentially alone okay represent uh
paschal
here alone okay uh uh
chairman vose is here so i have uh
18 present three missing but i will
uh if representative mcgee shows up i'll
okay thank you mr clerk representative
mcgee informed me
over the weekend that she has a
delegation subcommittee meeting this
morning
and she will join our meeting once she
gets out of that meeting
which could be around 10 30. i'm mocking
a present now
okay so the purpose of our meeting this
morning is to
discuss a couple of senate bills to
which we
are likely to make amendments the
calendar notice or the house scheduling
notice sent out by
committee assistant morris stated that
it would be just on senate bill 91 but
we're actually going to also talk about
senate bill 78 this morning as well as
senate bill 1991.
mr chair let me start with the pledge
and um
mr chair do we have a problem getting
i don't have a problem uh i don't know
uh if she has a problem or not it's it's
hard to tell at this point
i'm just putting together an email
message to represent callie pitts now
with a few things she might
want to try um
[Music]
okay for her audio yeah like
could we wait a few moments until she is
with us
can you hear i see you in here
i can hear you hear you no
sound no sound i missed a chair
i heard her say no sound reap well
hit the unmute we can certainly hear her
but
she's apparently not hearing us
mr chair yes representative bernardi
yes go ahead are you starting with the
pledge
yes we forgot to do that
[Music]
okay everybody at home please uh mute
your microphones
and join us as well and you're a thing
but i guess i'm not missing much
representative white will he is in the
pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance the flag of the
united states
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
jackie we can hear you i don't know if
thank you representative bernardi for
the reminder about the pledge
i appreciate that and a little bit of a
hectic morning uh the chairs and vice
chairs meeting which normally takes
place at nine o'clock this morning was
started late it didn't start till 9 30.
so i've been rushing around trying to
get here on time
that's the uh the result of
uh the cause for some of the uh
on our behalf mr chairman
you're muted no i'm sorry i i just
wanted to thank the chairman for his
efforts on our behalf
we understand it can be difficult trying
to be in two places at one
time okay thank you i appreciate that
all tournaments should be able to buy
locate
oh that's what it is buy locate right
representative callie pitts can you hear
us now now i can
i had to get out and come back
i don't know why so now you can hear us
excellent now i can
wonderful well in just a few minutes
i'd like to talk about uh senate bill
78 but before we do that
i need to alert the committee and have a
brief discussion
the senate concurs with the house of
representatives in the passage of the
following
in the passage of which amendments the
senate asks the concurrence of the house
of representatives
the bill in question is house bill 315
relative to the
and the senate modified this bill
twice they modified it in committee
by adding the language of senate bill
and the language of senate bill 109 is
very similar
to the language in house bill 106
which is a bill that we retained
and uh
it's it's a slightly um
paired down version of what was in house
bill 106 but
the portion that they kept was the
municipal host
the second amendment that the senate
added was a floor amendment that they
added
and the second amendment added
the language that's at the tail end
under utility property tax exclusion
and the reason reason they added that to
this bill is
because it goes along with senate bill
109 which they previously added
to house bill 315
[Music]
utility property tax exemptions
so that's the entirety of the
changes that they made to house bill
3-315
my inclination would be to concur with
these changes but i would like to hear
from other members of the committee
to hear what your opinions might be
on this question of concurrence
representative platt second chance for a
question mr chairman with all new res i
think i've got this
mr chairman with all due respect i
couldn't follow
all of those changes and so i have no
opinion
all right thank you uh representative
oxendine was recognized
thank you very much mr chair um i i
believe i'm agreeing with with the
representative put
i i would like to see the actual text
before i
and certainly before i uh could vote to
uh
to concur okay what i suggest you do in
that case
is go to the general court website
and look up senate bill 109
sb 109 you can there read the text
that the senate
has attached to house bill 315.
[Music]
and then the second part is the language
that's at the
end of senate bill 91
which we have before us today so those
are the two amendments that they
added to hb 315.
have you ever like to have an
opportunity to read them and consider
them before we
move to a concurrence vote
i'm not going to ask for a vote on
concurrence i just want to get
people's opinions thank you decision is
ultimately mine
but um i would like to hear what other
people have to say
so thank you representative
representative partial
you're recognized yes i'm sorry if i'm
being very concrete here but i am
looking at senate bill 109 as amended by
the senate
and is are we taking that language
verbatim
or have they altered it in order to fit
it into their
they took the language of senate bill
as passed by the senate and attached it
as an amendment to house bill 315.
and the second question i have i may
share
is um we are looking at amendment four
today
as part of our uh discussion and so
would be hard to find concurrence
with the amendment until we discuss it
no i don't think so because it's just
the utility property tax exemption
section
i think we can concur with that without
necessarily concurring
with all of part four of sb91
okay i'll trust in your judgment then
thank you so much okay
you probably want to keep me muted as
one of the bills one of the people who
worked on this bill very
hard i take umbrage at the senate
sending something over
uh with sight unseen i asked
three times because i could not pull up
the first amended version and
i could not get it so
going back to 109 was
the the amendment i believe is 1294 or
something like that but i could
not get the amendment i i couldn't pull
it up on the
website i called the clerk's office
and i think it's a great great
disadvantage
to be asking the committee
to concur on anything we have not been
able to see
and compare and contrast if we were in
the house right now we would be able to
go to a draw pull
out the bills and and look at them
and compare them and and make notes on
them
we have not been able to do that and the
senate loves to go for one scoop two
scoops three
oops four scoops on the bus an ad
well that's the truth and at this point
i don't know if i just disagree with
what they've done or not i think there
are some problems on it
we haven't had a public hearing on it we
haven't had
i i don't think they've had a hearing on
their amendment either
even though it's taken from another bill
and apparently there's
problems with that amendment um i want
to see it i'm one of those
show me people so i would
i don't know what's the deadline but i
believe we would probably at least have
another week
to look at this and i would love to
look at it probably go along with it i
don't know
and have at least another week i even
asked cliff
amendment house bill 315 and i got no
answer
he came back with 91 and what he was
looking at on 91
so i really would like to compare
and contrast and have that opportunity
um i've spent more on printer inc this
month
this year than i've ever spent because i
want the p
i want the paper in front of me i want
to see it
and it's right thank you and
that's all i can say is and if you're
gonna take that position
it's my bill and i'm going to
my decision i i i would take umbrage
with that and i don't
i i don't argue much but i i think we
need to
be able to thoroughly vet it
okay thank you for your comments let me
uh try to help everybody
understand how you can get access to the
language
of the amendment if you go to the build
docket
you should be able to see where the
senate attached
amendment number 2021-1294
s and if you click on
highlighted in blue in the build docket
and if you click on it it should bring
up the text of the amendment
so then you can read exactly what the
senate
that way if you have any doubts about
whether or not
you could agree you could accept
or concur with this amendment to 315
you'll have the language right in front
of you
and what is the floor amendment
if you go to senate bill 91 part 4
and look at the last portion of that
bill
it says utility property tax exclusion
from definition of utility property
the exact language that's in senate bill
part four about utility property tax
was added to this bill and the reason
they did that is because they were
not sure that senate bill 91 would pass
and out of our committee and so as a
result they wanted to make sure
this language got into statute so they
attached it as an amendment
to house bill 315. and does that have an
amendment number it must it does
it is 2021-1400s
representative vos i'm sorry to
interrupt but i can i can send those two
amendments around to the committee if
that would be helpful
yes yes that would be helpful thank you
i'll do that right now
thank you all right so let me back up a
little bit and explain
uh before i call on representative
harrington explain
so the senate passed senate bill 109.
it came out of the energy and natural
resources committee with a five to
nothing vote
and it then went to the senate floor
where it passed on a 24 to nothing
vote at that point the senate
tabled the bill now why did they do that
they did that because they didn't want
the bill to come to the house
they want they were afraid that if it
came to the house
that we would make changes to it in the
house
so they tabled the bill with the idea
that they would attach it to another
house bill
at a later date so that they could be
sure to get it passed
and in that regard they were probably
correct if senate bill 109 had come to
us
from the senate we probably would have
changed it here in the house
we have house bill 106 which we've
already discussed several times
and because we retained house bill 106
we can still make changes
to the language
that currently is now attached to house
so for a six or eight month period the
language in house bill 315 will be the
uh operable language but we can make
modifications to it later if we so
choose so that's how we got to the place
that we're at today and um
i hope that explanation helps everybody
understand
where we're where we are so
representative harrington uh
you're recognized for a comment um mr
jimmy let me start out by i realize it's
monday morning but i tell you you've got
me buffaloed
uh i'm still trying to figure out what
the hell's going on here
with 106 and 315 and 109 and
what is the actual thing that we're
looking to make a decision on whether we
agree with or not
and that's 315 as amended by
and i see three different amendments as
amended by the senate is that the final
thing we're looking at hb 315 as amended
by the senate and is uh
april 2021 0 7
4 8 8 a h
we're charged with making a decision
about whether to concur
or non-concur with the changes that the
senate made
okay and is there a place that we can
have and i think that someone said they
were going to do this
to see these in i'm assuming the first
amendment
must have come did that come out of the
house the one that's dated uh
april 9th no okay that was all came out
of the senate
so can we see those three amendments
by themselves so we can find out exactly
what they changed as compared to what we
sent over
because i thought 315 as we sent it was
pretty good
well let's be clear the first amendment
the one on april 9th came from
us okay the senate the only two
amendments that came for the senate
were 1294 s and 1400
s okay and jen for our committee
researchers said that she would send
those two amendments
via email to all members of the mike
okay that'll be very helpful because
trying to follow this otherwise is
trying to go back and look and see what
was exchanged or what was changed from
the senate version of the house version
it's kind of difficult to do so that'll
be helpful when we get them
okay thank you i appreciate that i
understand
that this is difficult
and ultimately i have to make the
decision on concur or non-concur
and as i indicated that at the beginning
of this conversation
my inclination is to concur but
uh i would appreciate hearing from
anybody else who has any
comments on this resolution
um yeah we've got the email from
but with those uh senate amendments now
at least i have okay well let's not
spend any more time on this
this morning since you guys want to read
those amendments
uh we'll talk about it again next monday
or tuesday when we have an exec session
on senate bill 78
senate bill 91 and senate bill 113.
we will be having exec sessions on those
three bills
either next monday the 24th for next
tuesday the 25th
there is a scheduling logistics error
situation that i'm dealing with right
now and so i don't know
exactly when we'll be doing it but i
should know by the end of the
day today which of those two days will
be having the exact session
so for now let's turn our attention to
senate bill 78
and i have sent everyone on the
committee
um a suggested amendment
to sen senate bill 78
which keeps the language
of the original bill but just adds
to it it adds the phrase
except when a veto of the biennial
budget occurs
and spending reverts to a continuing
resolution
only then shall renewable energy fund
expenditures require
approval by the general court fiscal
committee
that is the proposed amendment
what is the rationale for that amendment
well we're extremely fortunate
this morning to have an attendance here
in our committee
the chair of house finance division one
representative lynn ober and lynn
representative ober suggested to me
that this change might be necessary to
make this bill acceptable to the house
and
i've asked representative over if she
could come here this morning and tell us
about the rationale for making this
change so representative over
if you could move over to one of these
i would allow you to
give us an explanation for why you
thought
this language change was necessary
thank you mr chairman thank you
when we have a continuing resolution
that means that all spending that the
current legislature had
approved but the governor vetoed
is canceled and it reverts to
what is known as the previous biennium
or the continuing resolution continues
the budget
everybody has been operating for the
last two years
this year for example we passed a budget
that's
lower with tax cuts that's gone to the
senate
but should that fail and we would revert
we would revert to a budget that spends
a great deal more money
with no tax cuts every agency would like
to have all of their
money so that nobody can tell them how
to spend it
if you put it into a dedicated fund
which this does and we do that a lot
and then you say it is continually
appropriated
you do not know or have any control over
how that money is being spent
but if you use the amendment that the
chairman suggested
when there is a continuing resolution
any agency that wants to spend above and
beyond what was in the previous
budget i.e not in the continuing
resolution
must come to fiscal committee explain
their project justify why it needs to be
done now
and get the approval and there are a lot
of agencies that do that now for example
parks programs under construction are
normally done in the summer we have a
hard time constructing up here in the
winter
so if the budget fails and we have for
example a million dollars worth
of improvements in two of our parks that
are needed in the coming year for safety
and expansion for people
they could not do that but they could
come to fiscal and say
here's our proposal here's the money
we'd like approval to go ahead
so if you use this amendment you give
the legislature
the continued right to control spending
until a budget passes finance has been
starting to put this kind of language
into many of the dedicated funds
that exist today thank you mr chairman
thank you representative over i have a
question
if the money that goes into the
renewable energy fund
does not come from the budget but
alternative compliance payments that the
utilities
make when they can't buy renewable
energy credits
does that make a difference no it
doesn't we should really be controlling
whatever spending
is going on during our biennium
even if we do not have access to a
budget
you don't know what was in the previous
one previous budgets can spend money
out of every dedicated fund if they want
you simply put that section into house
bill 2
and you have suspended the law if the
veto
of the budget is made then the old house
bill 2 which suspends the law
continues so there are a lot of things
that can go on
that may not be what you expected to
have
okay thank you representative harrington
is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman um and thank you
lynn for uh stepping in here today this
has been very helpful
question for you though the um if it
talks about when a veto of the biennial
budget occurs what if there's just a
budget isn't passed
because it comes up for a vote and we
don't get a majority vote
does that need to be addressed as well
it would seem like would fit into the
same circumstances of the veto
yeah if the budget doesn't pass mike you
are correct it would go to a continuing
resolution
i don't know is how the majority party
ever goes to the floor
when you're coming up to for the final
vote on the budget without a continuing
resolution in their pocket
because you cannot simply do things like
close the state hospital and kick all
the people on the street and
kick all the neighbors off say no you
can't get your car registered no you
can't renew your driver's license you
have to have a way to continue
basic functions that are going on in the
state that we all rely on
i i guess my question is does this need
to be addressed would we have to say
accept when a
is this says when a veto and it reverts
to a contingency
i hear would you say i didn't actually
write that language
your point is correct i would think
since this is the chairman's language
that is up to him whether he wants to do
it that way
or just when there is a veto so your
point is correct if it said if a budget
didn't pass
whether it be a veto or a lack of vote
on the floor
you would take care of it but the
chairman could also write an amendment
this way
that it would affect only a veto so this
is his language not mine
thank you thanks for clarifying that
point
uh representative harrington that would
seem to indicate that
some additional language would be
necessary here so we'll
i'll make a note of that one other thing
i should point out
well no i'll point that out later
representative callie pitts you're
recognized for a question
representative oba i'm a very simplistic
thinker so when this amendment passes
does it change anything does it still
allow the fiscal committee
to spend the money in the energy fund
whatever way it wants which it would do
anyway if we didn't have this particular
amendment
it allows that's a good question but it
allows the fiscal committee not to spend
it any way they want
but to reply positively to the agency
request
so you have that control whether you say
it or not but the fiscal committee
cannot write its own proposal to spend
the money
it only reply it only responds
so i again i i may i clarify
yes go ahead again so that my
my brain under wraps around this
this money we have no budget this law
goes away until we do have a budget
correct
and then without a budget
if there's money in the energy fund
could we
take that money for instance or could
the fiscal committee
take what they believe is excess or
money that's not committed and use it
say
for education no they cannot they cannot
write their own proposal
so they can only use it for energy they
can only respond to the agency request
and i assume the agency would
only ask to spend it on energy
thank you thank you uh representative
samsuche is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
um i just want to ask you whether
you believe that this this language here
helps
us with the problem we're trying to
solve here we've heard
from uh during testimony about this that
one of the problems we have right now is
that
uh projects energy efficiency and
renewable energy projects
are are often put on hold all of a
sudden
if uh the uh once the
the budget year comes to an end even if
there's money in that budget
unless they can unless everything is
paperwork is completed on time
they have to wait till the next budget
appropriation
until they can fund these projects and
in the meantime the energy
fund has money there but it was from
last
last year's appropriations and
i believe that the the idea be behind
this bill
was to make sure that the money that was
there
from last year's appropriation continued
to be used for this purpose
going forward so that businesses have a
predictability about
when there's a project that's been
approved that they're going to get that
kind of funding
um does this do you think this helps in
any way
alleviate that problem if the project's
been approved the money has already been
allocated so even there's no reason for
a project to stop
at the end of one year if the money's
been allocated this would allow you
to have control over new projects going
forward in the small period of time when
okay thank you okay thank you uh
representative mann is recognized for a
question
thank you mr chairman this is uh trivial
almost in in
importance but i think the uh second
line says this lawn
this non-lapsing special fund shall be
continually appropriated
uh it deleted the sentence that that
just
the declarative sentence that stated
that the fund
was non-lapsing i think it should be
a declarative sentence a separate one
saying it is non-lapsing period
uh i think this sentence as it reads is
just assuming that it's non-lapsing it
doesn't
it's not a proper way to state
that it's not like a lapsing fund
my own opinion in terms of the english
okay thank you for that comment
representative oxendine is recognized
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative ober uh
this is an unusual dedicated fund the
the monies come
from these it's dedicated where they
come from and it's dedicated where
they're going to
we have had testimony from the agency
that they are in a bind because of
recent change to the text about
non-lapsing and continually appropriated
the issue that you have raised with us
is a separate issue
let's leave the language alone the
language of the bill was
is fine the way it came to us
and we all there was consensus
from the from the group about it the
last time we discussed it
the the issue that you've brought about
this particular exceptional circumstance
where you might
not have a budget is is something else
to be tacked on
and uh it doesn't it doesn't modify
whether or not the money is carried
forward but but we have a real
problem with renewable energy projects
that they can only apply for the funding
at a certain time
and they they go forward with the
project and then you get to the end of
the fiscal year and the project hasn't
been completed and if they haven't
completed it
they don't get the money and and they
can't get the money
after in the new fiscal year either so
we have
we have a very large sum sitting there
we have people desperate to get these
projects accomplished and get
so i i don't want to take you into any
more detail
i thank you for being here and i thank
you for explaining the bit about the
continuing resolution it's important
and and we should add that but let's not
get involved with the lap scene and the
continually appropriated
that was all settled last time we have
okay thank you uh representative samsit
no i didn't sorry okay
okay i see no more uh
hands raised so representative over i
want to thank you for being here
to uh give us those explanations we
really appreciate that
happy to do it mr chairman i would um i
would point out that there is one other
uh potential change uh suggested by this
amendment
suggest proposed amendment and that is
it
adds section two
electrical electric renewable portfolio
standards
amend rsa 362 f colon 4
dash ic to read as follows c
hydrogen derived from biomass fuels
water or methane gas
now that language was originally in
senate bill 113
and if you'll all recall during the
public hearing for 113
senator bradley suggested that senate
bill 113
be retained and during the public
hearing i asked him i said
should the section about hydrogen
derived from
biomass fuels water and methane be
extracted and put in another bill and he
said
yes that would be appreciated
so what we've done or what i've done
with this proposed amendment is pull
that section out of 113
and added it to senate bill 78
i discussed this with senator bradley
and he said
that he agrees with that change so that
is the
other proposed change for this amendment
is there any comment on that change
seeing none okay representative oxen
i'm sorry i i had anticipated we were
talking about 91 today and so i don't
have the 78 materials in front of me
as i recall it was just that one word
water that was added
yes that is correct thank you very much
for
clarifying representative sausage
yeah i just want to say i think that's a
reasonable thing to do i agree with that
too
okay any further comments about
senate bill 78 okay
let's move on then i would like
now to talk about senate bill 91.
likely require some amendment to the
language
and the first section i'd like to
discuss is part one
i sent the committee
copies of suggested amendment language
for part one
and part four so you all should have it
i'd be interested in hearing your
comments on
the proposed language most of the
changes
involved changing phrases like
fair compensation etc that was
in the original language fair share
and that kind of thing to a language
determines is is more
reasonable for these kinds of for this
kind of legislation
and that language is just and reasonable
so you'll notice in several places in
the uh
in the proposed amendment we change fair
share
to just and reasonable contribution
or compensation justin reasonable for
parties just in reasonable costs
etc etc um
we had discussed those changes of the
last work session
and so i've incorporated them into this
suggested
i've also added the word actual in a
couple of places
in front of transmission and
distribution costs
and i changed on page
three line nine and ten
the definition of electric generation
equipment
to read that electric generation
equipment in this chapter means
any equipment that qualifies as energy
storage
as defined in rsa 74 etc
such equipment shall not be subject to
any of the requirements of section 3 of
this job
and that language is more precise
the intent of the original legislation
which was to exclude
energy storage equipment from the
provisions of this chapter
so those are the suggested proposed
amendment uh changes
yes uh thank you very much uh
these there there's a lot of other
changes in here as well there
um in general i think that these are
positive changes
that make a lot of sense um i'm
a little i i would really like to be
able to change lines
9 through 12 on the last
page and i think
unfortunately i did not staple my pages
together and so now i'm getting one page
from one amendment
with the other amendment i believe it
was the second one that you
actually you were you were just speaking
about the definition about
primary and electric generation
equipment primary energy
this is at the very i think it's the
last part of the second amendment that
you proposed
are we in the same place yes that that
is the
last uh amendment change that i
discussed yes
i'm not i'm not suggesting anything
substantive i just find
the um the lines nine through 12 to be
awkward
and and difficult to read and i'm not
sure that our intention would be
completely clear
um if this were ever to become a matter
of contention
so i just kind of a highlight that i i
might come in with a proposed amendment
next week
if if that seemed
reasonable the um the
the line 14 about the
benefit to low-income customers uh seems
like a a very um
useful change um it it again
it's been in the bill before but this
highlights it
uh
i think the the most important issue is
that the last time we had
our discussion we talked about going
beyond
simply transmission and distribution
costs and
i remember uh representative bernardi
suggesting
that uh or at least reiterating
that reliability and resiliency were
something that uh were of such an
advantage
that we would want to include them as
did you consider that when you were
creating this amendment
did you not include it because of
i don't see anywhere in my notes um
well i did send you an email with some
suggested language changes in
in that email i i actually quoted uh
representative bernardi
uh he was summarizing our discussion at
the end and
saying that the things that we seem to
and did you send specific language uh
proposed language
yes and in fact you you and i had a
at least a bit of an email exchange
where i uh apologized for being late in
recognizing that you had um sent me a
an acknowledgement that you had received
uh my
language changes and i did receive your
email
and i went over your language changes
with senator waters
and we both thought that some of your
changes were just too
um involved and too
detailed for the purposes of this
uh legislation i don't specifically
remember anything about
reliability
the reliability and resiliency were not
part of any of the specific
texts that i had suggested they
it was in the um in the body of the
paragraph
we hadn't we hadn't devised a way of
getting it into the bill
not to restrict the bill
and and i must say you have language
here which says including
it perhaps if we said including but not
limited to
because you only have two things listed
sorry somebody uh just distracted me
what line specifically are we looking at
now
uh this i believe we're in this are we
in the same place
on page 3 i believe at least the way it
um okay the line about electric
generation equipment
in this chapter means is that online no
no i i don't think we're there
it's it's the why it's the page that
starts with the header
customer energy storage
actually peter i i was in error i
believe the point is right at the very
beginning
on lines one through three
for behind the meter storage the rules
or orders shall allow for bring your own
device peak reduction program
a new language the commission may
approve mechanisms for a utility to
compensate such
projects for the value they actually
provide
including and then there's a substantial
amount struck out
so including any transmission or
distributional costs
actually avoided because of the
non-utility energy storage
project to the extent practicable based
on determinable cost
components so my suggestion here is
simply adding
rather than get into a lengthy
discussion about how we might get
resiliency and reliability
in here even though those were issues
that we discussed
last time and we seem to have arrived at
okay i've made a note of that um that
seems like a reasonable
change thank you very much thank you
uh representative callie pitts
yeah i i i'm just actual
transmission costs how do you quantify
what is being proposed
reliability how do you declare the
reliability of
the sun for storage or the
you know i i don't understand that we're
going with concrete here we're going
with limited
why are we expanding it all of a sudden
to generalities
um i i don't
i don't buy that all right i can't i
can't
fathom that at this point how do you
quantify what's reliable
um our own grid isn't reliable
so how do you quantify that
i i don't i don't understand that and i
i think that when we get into that kind
of a weed
on this particular thing we're now
making it more complicated than it
really should be
we can get to what actual costs are but
we can't get to some
of these things that can't be quantified
and i and i i think we should leave it
alone
that's all thank you thank you for that
comment representative harrington is
recognized for comment
thank you mr chairman uh two quick
things first the just for the record the
justin reasonable
term that's actually not a puc creation
that's right out of uh
ferc rules and federal law that's where
it comes from so that's the appropriate
term to use
i have to agree with uh representative
kelly pitts on this one this
uh including actual avoided transmission
and distribution costs i mean that is
really a
real difficult not to crack when you're
talking about an individual project
and you're going to say that you know if
you're talking we're tracking
small fairly small customers here and
how much they're going to save off of
the billion dollar transmission system
because they're creating you know a few
megawatts somewhere
and is then you're going to get in the
time base because remember the
transmission is based on
the maximum demand for power
on whatever that day is in the year
that's what the transmission and
distribution systems are based on
and this i have to agree with her is a
very very complicated thing to try to
come up and assess the value to
uh we don't do it for a lot of things
for instance if you put in a new
power plant you don't get credit for the
transmission uh updates that didn't have
to get built because the power plant
wasn't there
uh that's that that doesn't get uh
that's just savings and transmission
costs the power plant builder
doesn't get any uh rebate saying well by
building this plant if we didn't put it
in
we were gonna have to put in a 500
million dollar uh transmission system
but
since you put this 800 megawatt whatever
here uh you're going to save
transmission costs well
that's good but we're not going to pay
you anything for that so now in this
case we're saying well if it does do it
somehow we're going to pay it for them
so it's not only it's not consistent it
is incredibly difficult to try to come
up with i think this thing should be
just
left out
okay thank you for that comment uh
representative sausage
um well i i gotta agree with both
kim representative callie pitts and
representing harrington about this
but uh on the other hand um i think the
the verbiage that's already there that
we are talking
i think on line 11 of the value
provided to the electricity system and
we might be able to kind of boil this
down to say
that just and reasonable compensation
should be provided
for the value provided to the
electricity system as determined by the
commission
uh and uh representative tried to be
more specific about that by saying
that that includes uh other things
it includes the avoided transmission and
distribution costs but her
language also mentions things like
uh determinable reliability and
resiliency benefits
and uh that that sounds vague but
but those things are done all the time
when there's a reliability project
or a resiliency project that is
often justification for a project so
it's not so big
but i agree that we should try to strike
out all these uh
terminologies and and allow the
commission to determine
what the value of that contribution is
to the electric system
and we also we already say that they
should be
justly and reasonably compensated for
the value whatever that is
how whatever can be determined as the
value
without us getting into the details of
that so we're not excluding anything but
we're allowing
uh the commission to determine what is
the value here
so representative stops that you would
advocate on line 10
striking the language including actual
avoided transmission
and distribution costs yes mr chairman i
would suggest after justin reasonable
compensation
i shall provide that uh for the
and i would take the the uh two lines
below it that phrase
for the value it provides to the
electricity system as determined by the
commission
okay thank you uh representative
calipets okay i'm i'm gonna play the
devil's advocate here
what it what if these projects
are not valuable but because they become
so numerous
become a problem with intermittent power
and entering the grid so
would people then be charged
because there's a problem and we have
seen
with the proliferation of some of these
projects small projects have caused
problems
that intimate intermittent electricity
well if we if the question is what is
the
value of that yeah electricity then
that's
to be determined by the commission to be
that reasonable i don't know
representative occident
thank you uh first to the point raised
by representative kelly pitts
the whole point of this is it deals with
storage
this is what makes intermittent power
not intermittent
this is this is this is the the great
step forward in technology
to making distributed resources more
available
so uh i i think you should feel
reassured by the fact that this is
uh promoting energy storage uh back to
the
to uh your discussion chairman votes
with um
representative samson i'm a little
concerned that
what he said and what you said didn't
dovetail i don't believe and correct me
if i'm wrong
representative some such i don't believe
he wanted to eliminate the language
about avoided
distribution and transmission charges i
he his point his point was different
from that so i i wanted to make sure we
didn't
lose that issue um and and then the the
final point i wanted to make
was that again using a concrete example
if the utility is faced with a choice
between putting in a substation
it's going to cost 5 million rather than
or putting in a storage system that's
going to cost
3 million to meet the same problem the
same
issue on their system they're saving 2
million dollars
if they if that is the choice that is
made
if they're doing this on their own
then then that's all handled inside of
their own utility
but if they're working with an outside
um
third party the question is is there a
way to
encourage and incentivize this very
positive technology to be developed
by having a share in that value
apportioned
to the third party and again this is not
the kind of thing we can determine here
what we're saying is there's a possible
value here
if the puc can determine it if it's
clear that there's a money value
then this is what we want you to do
that's that's what we're saying okay
thank you
uh representative harrington
representative
representatives options do you want to
answer her question
i i agree with representative oxford i
didn't
mean to say we should drop the phrase
including actual avoided transmission
distribution costs
i wanted to move that phrase of
for the value provided to the electorate
system to be moved up
uh and after compensation
and then to be and then furthermore it
says as determined by the commission
including that okay i get it
okay thank you now representative hamil
harrington you're up
thank you mr chairman yeah just to
reiterate the obviously cost effective
storage is the uh
it's the golden uh spike if you will
that we're looking for if we
we're going to be obviously been going
forward with a lot of intermittent power
whether it's solar or wind
and this is the thing that makes it work
much better
so we obviously cost effective storage
is a is a big plus
it's a game changer uh just to put these
things in perspective when we're talking
about transmission costs and
just so i think maybe people uh get a
better handle of how this is done
when a project comes up through iso new
england a reliability project
they put in a preliminary estimated
budget and then they use that to see if
the project
is justified going through a process
ultimately that goes down to ferc and
ferc approves that
now what the first thing they file the
transmission company is with ferc is
saying that
regardless what happens to this project
once it's approved
all reasonable costs all prudent costs
will be funded
to the transmission company even if the
project gets cancelled and never gets
completed
so that then ferc says yep we're going
to do that you're going to get them even
if the project's cancelled and completed
but here's the thing you got to remember
the iso new england criteria unless it's
changed and i don't think it has
is the estimate is supposed to be within
minus 50 percent to plus 200 percent
and i'll give you an example of one of
the largest projects ever done in new
england
which was southwest connecticut phase
two
it came in at about almost to the penny
200 percent over the original estimate
so
making this out as some kind of an exact
science where someone's going to say
all right if you put in this storage
system here
it's going to save us x amount of
dollars on transmission
uh that's a kind of a myth because
no one has any clue as to how much that
transmission is actually going to cost
when you have a procedure when you have
a policy that says minus 50
to plus 200 percent and i got to tell
you i've never seen the minus 51 but
i've seen a hell of a lot of plus 200
projects it's just isn't that an exact
the science
it okay
um can can you hear me uh hang on a
second
actually actually i need to recognize
representative
first sure thank you i find it ironic
that uh
we encourage uh distributed resources
generation which may have a deleterious
effect
on the system reliability and
and uh resilience and
and don't hit them with any cost for
that but now we want
some people want to try to compensate
storage to offset
the bad stuff that's occurring with
distributed resources
i just find a dichotomy they were
thinking
um and with respect to representative
harrison's point about transmission what
he said was true in a planning estimate
only
when it gets down to the point of
production they're a lot closer than
that
okay thank you okay now representative
oxford
if i may mr chairman just to clarify
that that's what
fred said is is correct but that's
the point of approval is using the
planning estimate and once it's been
approved if they get more exact as they
go along
but they're already going to get all the
prudent costs that's the point i was
okay thank you representative occident
yes and and can you hear me yes no
thank you very much i i think the point
here is not
at least my understanding of of this
text
was that this these are costs that are
determined after the fact
the utility comes before the puc and
says we spent
x this was our thinking we could have
done that but we did
this these are actuals
they're not working prospectively
they're working
on the the what's the word the
repayment getting approval
so they know what they're called all
right thank you
okay i think uh i think we've gone over
everything we need to cover on that
proposed amendment we'll have a couple
of changes coming
before we see the final amendment so
with the remaining
50 minutes we have for this uh
this session let's talk about
part four this is the limited energy
limited electrical energy producers
section
of senate bill 91
and this is the section
provides us with the most difficulty i
think
because there is still some question
in my discussion with a lot of people
about whether
any of this is in fact
legal
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
allow the honorable clifton below to
speak and i'm going to ask
mr bilo if you could answer a couple of
questions
to help us understand if this
actually can be done legally or not
the first question i want to ask
is if you look at page two of the
proposed amendment
starting at line 14 it says
that the limited producers shall receive
credit
etc etc etc but i'm still not
clear who provides
those credits so mr bilo could you
answer that question for me
sure thank you mr chairman um
essentially what what this overall
section does
is clarify
the state jurisdiction over distributed
generation and storage that is not
participating in iso new england markets
and sort of under the federal state
overall scheme
um there's there's not supposed to be
any gaps in regulation
and under the federal power act and the
ferc
and supreme court interpretations of it
they say very clearly the state has
jurisdiction over retail
sales of electricity as well as within
state wholesale
so within state wholesale sales sell to
another party for resale
only occurs for generation which is not
subject to ferc uh jurisdiction so that
that's
all we're dealing with here stuff that
is by its nature state jurisdictional
the transmission credit um would come
from what's called the transmission cost
adjustment mechanism
it is in effect part of retail rates not
the wholesale rates
the transmission owners and iso new
england would continue to charge the
distribution utilities transmission
service costs based on their share of
the monthly
annual up not monthly monthly not annual
on the monthly coincident peak because
the transmission charges
are actually parceled out for the whole
year uh based on
a single hour of peak demand in each
month of the year
and so um the the the
the in essence the revenue comes because
all customers are paying two and a half
cents a kilowatt hour
roughly for transmission it's a flat per
kilowatt hour rate even though the
underlying cost
is based on share of coincident peak so
so
you know it by its nature some customers
have more of that
peak demand and others less but everyone
gets charged the same amount and to my
mind that's a deficiency
in not providing an appropriate price
signal that that generation
or storage that's on system peak is much
more valuable than
system generation or storage that is
off-peak
for instance so just as a as a mechanism
it recognizes that
okay if you've got one megawatt that is
generated locally
and is used to offset load locally
um then that is one megawatt that you do
not have to buy from the transmission
over the transmission grid from bulk
larger generators under iso under first
jurisdiction
so um that is in its nature
sort of a state regulated transaction
and the state
only the puc only has to ensure that the
tr that the distribution companies get
reimbursed the full
amount of the transmission charges that
go to them through whatever mechanism
so so if for instance a one megawatt uh
distributed generator limited producer
under this statute not participating in
net metering
was producing one megawatt for every
um hour on every coincident peak hour of
every month of the year for
instance um which is unlikely you know
they're going to vary by month and if
it's
solar or even with solar with storage
maybe not so much in the wintertime
but it would it would be avoiding
the cost of about a hundred and thirty
dollars per kw
of that capacity that is not being
charged to the distribution utility
and instead they could be compensated
in effect 95 or less of that i say 95
or less because it's based on its output
before accounting for
transmission and transformation and line
losses
and there's further language in here
that if there's any issue about any
cross subsidy or cost shifting that the
commission could reduce that to a lower
percentage
uh but the basic point is if we don't
have this kind of generation in the one
to five megawatt range in the storage
then and we get that from the bulk
system we will pay
the hundred and thirty dollars per kw
per year
uh uh for you know our on our based on
our peak demands
if we can shave that peak demand then
there is a true avoided cost
it's actually quite discernible it is
the basis for liberty utilities
battery pilot which they're doing and
this simply
says let's that make make the same
principle that's being applied by the
puc with liberty utilities
make that same principle apply to a
a a a third party owned battery storage
system
or generator that can produce on peak
most solar
does not produce on that peak so the
idea that this will give a lot of
compensation to bare solar is not likely
unless the solar is designed to produce
on the monthly system coincident peak
which in the winter time is after dark
so this really
provides the point is to provide an
appropriate price signal which is to say
if you can reduce our cost from what
they would otherwise be
by x amount then you get 95 or less of
that x amount
and the rest of that savings could go to
other customers
so that that's a long answer to a short
question thank you
was a very long answer but what i
understood from that answer
is that there would definitely be
some kind of cost shifting no
because because the customer the retail
customer would still be
paying the exact same amount they're
paying for transmission now
it's just that they would pay most of it
to the transmission provider
in effect a small part of it would go to
a limited producer
that actually avoids that transmission
cost so
you know it's it's sort of a but four if
if you think we're going to get one to
five megawatt
limited producers without such a credit
then that that might be true they would
be producing savings that they're not
getting credit for
but i think it's unlikely we're going to
get that um
and instead we're going to see a push to
expand net metering which
overcompensates in one realm
generation and under compensates in
another realm
which is not giving credit for avoided
transmission costs
but the first part of that lengthy
sentence you said
that customers will still pay
the transmission charges to their
utility
but the limited producer
will pay slightly less than that so
that has them yes no they won't
necessitate
no no because the limited producer
the limited producer only gets credit
for
the actual charges that they have helped
reduce or eliminate
and and in the long run there's value to
this because
um you are avoiding or you know the ins
the structural incentive would be to
shift
shave the peak the coincident peak
demand which
you know the more people do that the
wider the target becomes in terms of the
number of hours you need to perform
uh to achieve that reduction um
and if you can do so then that actually
helps avoid the need to
have expensive more new transmission
investment
because you wouldn't need it to serve
that load uh it would be served locally
instead
just like energy efficiency or
or load shifting um well load shifting
doesn't do it because you would pay
you pay regardless of when when you
consume
right so the second question about
this whole issue is if the transmission
and distribution grids
are so tightly integrated
is it going to be possible to determine
or to segregate avoided transmission
charges
from charges
i i think yes because it's quite
discreet it's it's
it's about 11 per kw per month
and it's a simple measurement the uh
distribution utility gets a bill based
on what their network load is
at that hour of system peak this
only gives credit if the if the
discharge to the grid either from
generation or storage
actually occurs at that hour of system
peak and just like liberty
calculates how much their batteries are
saving each month
uh because they figure out how much
they've actually discharged the
batteries
at the system peak in the same manner
you know the same calculation occurs and
says okay you've got
one megawatt that you produced on system
peak
that lowered our transmission costs by
1.05 megawatts or 1.07
reduces it by 1.07 megawatts on average
and we would have to pay for 1.07
instead we'll pay you for one
or or less than one and
there's no cost shift there there's a
small savings that
uh could grow over time as we avoid
uh some transmission investments that
may otherwise be necessary
if we're getting this power from a
remote resource rather than
a very local resource you know so so
yeah the
the two systems are integrated but there
is an interface between them
and reducing load on the distribution
system whether it's by
load curtailment energy efficiency
storage
or distributed generation all has the
same actual effect
of lowering the amount of power that has
to be moved over the transmission grid
and hence the size that that system has
to be built to
okay so the next question is
will the
rates that utilities
need to charge to recover their costs
be affected by these limited producer
credits
the transmission utilities yes for
the distribution the transmission
utilities
well there'll be two effects one is um
they'll get
they'll get less revenue for a
particular month in which this
um sort of reduced network load occurs
um that this is this is something that
the
um just last week or beginning of this
week the markets committee of iso new
england
voted 94.4 in favor of a tariff
clarification that
that makes it clear that such generation
would not
um would function to reduce the
calculation of network load
so yes the network load calculation
would go
down and the annual system peak for
capacity charges as well would go
down to the extent that we have new
storage or generation
at the system peaks um that has two
effects one for transmission
um you know combined with everything
else that's going on with the economy
with energy efficiency
with beneficial electrification load
being added to the system
um it might uh reduce um
the the um revenue uh
towards their revenue requirement and
they have a correction mechanism so in
theory the revenue
uh the next time they recalculate that
there might be a shortfall or there
might be an overage
um and and that will go into the
calculation for the next period of time
but it also has the longer run effect of
reducing
the need for new investment in
transmission to some extent
and what we know is that new investment
in transmission
a new say you know megawatt of capacity
on the transmission grid
cost a lot more than the average
megawatt of capacity does today
so adding more transmission at to serve
peak loads
has an effect of um of of raising
the cost per kw of demand over time um
and and the other fact is if we can
shave these peaks
and we actually have more consumption
off-peak such such as a battery that
drop you know it's charged up off-peak
and discharges on peak then we're
actually potentially selling more
kilowatt hours total so
there is a potential positive effect of
spreading cost over more kilowatt hours
uh without raising the peak demand which
will have the effect of
okay representative plett is recognized
for a question for a couple if you don't
mind mr chamberlain or a couple of
questions
uh i would ask uh
whether the uh
let's say a leap is perused let's say it
happens to be in lebanon
selling to customers and somehow that
does avoid
let's say a peak uh at the lebanon
interface with the eversource system
what happens with that transmission does
i i'm not sure i understood the question
um
we would have to have a huge amount of
such distributed generation and storage
to be able to zero out our our
load at the system peak if we if we're
able to do it at system peak we could
probably do it all the time
and in fact in effect we will set up a
huge micro grid um that that that's
we're
you know really really far off from that
um
um so
you know if in theory everybody produced
so much local power that they didn't
need transmission that that's true
the in the transmission system would
still cost money but
i think the trend is the opposite
there's a big push
uh to increase electrification of
vehicles
and um heating with heat pumps and such
uh so i think we're likely to continue
to see growth and load the question is
do we manage the peak uh demand or not
so so that we can kind of lower the cost
per kilowatt hour
hour or or if we don't have the price
signals in place
like like we we don't have it with
regular net metering
um uh there's no time differential on
the kilowatt hours in that metering
uh so if you don't have some price
mechanisms to recognize there's value
just
to reducing peak demands then
then we potentially will drive up the
cost per kilowatt hour for everyone
because
people don't care whether they're adding
load on peak or off peak
it's there's no financial signal for
that
my follow-up question is whether what
the purpose of transmission is simply
delivery of uh power to uh
distribution system or are there other
intents for that transmission
such as voltage regulation frequency
regulation
etc oh yes i mean
most of our power like you know probably
of it comes from these bulk generators
that are part of
iso ferc regulated ice new england
market and and they can provide those
services
um typically uh battery storage
can also provide those services they can
do voltage regulation power factor
correction
uh things like that with with smart
inverters uh so potentially
and distribution utilities have to do
some of that on their distribution grid
as well
with capacitors and such these
additional
distributed energy resources can
actually be used to help
manage and improve power quality on the
okay thank you uh representative
representative harrington you have a
question
your hand is up
all right we'll come back to that uh
anybody else
have a question or a comment
okay representative occident you're
recognized
thank you very much mr chairman and
thank you uh mr velo
i think i'm sorry i'm going i'm going to
not ask the question i think it would
take us
into a a different rabbit hole that
might not be
as productive as i originally thought
excuse me okay thank you
uh representative harrington are you
i guess not all right i'm going to throw
out a different
suggestion and that is i'm sorry i had
my just forgot to take my hand down
which i will do now
oh okay thank you uh
all right before i toss out my
suggestion i'll recognize
while we have cliff here i'm i'm i'm
really concerned cliff about the
about the uh resiliency of the of the
grid
and the possible cyber jacks on the grid
lower that or do you need that
that ability perhaps to
or do you need batteries to operate
the electricity to operate that storage
mechanism representative callie pitts
i'm going to respectfully
ask you to withdraw that question since
it's not really relevant to the
uh bill that we're discussing the
section of the legislation that we're
discussing
could you take that question offline
with uh mr b
cliff could you answer that by email for
me
is he going sure will do yes by email
that's true okay thank you so
the suggestion i'm going to toss out is
given the uncertainty
around the issues raised by this
legislation how would the committee feel
about
creating a study committee to study this
issue
to come up with a proposal that
seems to be to seems that can deal with
all the
vagueness and the unanswered questions
that we seem to have about this bill
that's my proposal and i'd like to hear
including you representative milo
i think we've studied it to death and we
should push it forward
representative oxendine
we have a situation where the puc is
currently
examining the storage issue and they are
well along in their deliberations
i think possibly retaining
the bill and let's see what the puc
tells us they think they can do
which was in fact the upshot of the
of the previous legislation that was
passed
okay well thank you for that suggestion
but since this is an omnibus bill with
five parts to it i'm not sure we could
retain
[Music]
one part i think we'd have to retain the
entire bill
representative um thank you mr chair
the awards wording you have there now is
just unreasonable
i think the commission can figure out
and there may be a lot of uncertainty
but they'll take that uncertainty into
account and come up with whatever they
come up with
all right now we're starting to confuse
parts one and parts
okay very good uh the justin reasonable
language was language we were going to
add to part one
now we're trying to figure out what to
do with part four which is the
limited electrical producer energy
producers
section and i'd like to hear mr bilo
comment on whether or not you think that
we could obtain any additional
information by creating a study
committee
um i i think you could um
create a study committee to look at how
to
update rsa 362 a2a this whole section
about limited producers
um another another idea that i'll just
throw out
is uh you could um make
the enactment of part four uh
effective put it off until january one
of next year
and say that the commission that that
the rules
uh under it shall not be effective
before july 1
of next year uh and then also set up the
study
committee uh to take a another look at
it and then you
have plenty of time to introduce and
pass legislation before
any implementing rules become effective
to modify
or clean it up or um or repeal it for
that matter
but but i guess my concern is you've got
this house rule
that um language that was ital'd in the
first year of the session
can't be uh taken up in the second year
and and you've already killed two bills
that are somewhat similar
uh so so i guess that's my concern in in
suggesting
maybe a uh enactment that's delayed
uh uh by enough to give time for study
committee to review it
um but yes i mean i i do think you
probably
benefit from people understanding this
okay good thanks for that uh
thanks for that suggestion although i
think the senate could refile this bill
i don't think their rules are the same
as the house rules
that that might be possible if if we
change this just to a study committee
representative oxenam you still have
your hand up do you want to make another
comment
[Music]
i'm trying to figure out but between the
if
we could retain the entire bill um
is there a loss to the other sections is
there anything that we need
um the question you tell me
part one is the energy storage piece
does that need to be uh that's the part
that we were
suggesting to retain was part one and
you said we couldn't do just part one
we'd have to do the entire bill because
it's an omnibus
so i'm wondering if what just trying to
think through what it would be like to
retain the bill
i think the suggestion was that we
retain
or we could retain part four
but now you're suggesting that we retain
the whole bill
so that's a that's a possibility
representative mcgee welcome uh i hope
you had a good delegation meeting
and thank you i'd like to hear your
thoughts thank you mr chairman it went
a lot longer than it was supposed to go
but it was productive
um i guess i'm you know i'm coming late
to the party here
and what i'm hearing is that we have
questions
on part four and since hb
407 was a bill that i had put in and
i've been in some of the conversations
um leading up to today i'm just curious
if we have clearly articulated what
those questions
are you're saying there's confusion
around
uh you know if the bill went forward as
part of the omnibus
how uh that there might be some things
for which there aren't clarification and
i think
some of that comes from us not having an
understanding about how the puc is going
to rule but they are
going to have to figure out how limited
electric energy producers
operate properly and are compensated
properly
in the space so i'm just wondering if
we've identified in the conversation
what the particular
exceptions are uh to passing for along
with everything else is part of the
omnibus
i'm not i wasn't paying attention to
exactly when you joined
the meeting so i don't know it wasn't
very long ago
i don't know how much of it you missed
but yes i did articulate about three or
four different questions
oh you did earlier that we discussed
with
while his answers were as as always
extremely
they still left me with with a few
questions so
what we're discussing now is the
possibility of
creating a study committee to
try to come up with answers to those
remaining questions
and mr bilo's suggestion
that we just changed the effective date
of this act from what it says currently
that it'll take effect
60 days after its passage we could
change that to a year from now year and
a half from now
and also add append a study committee
section to the bill and
have the study committee try to answer
those questions
before the bill becomes goes into effect
and if the result of that study
committee was that the bill should not
go into effect
then we could submit legislation to uh
to repeal it so that's the question
we're
working on at the moment
which i think is a reasonable
potentially reasonable
approach yeah i would agree okay
thank you if we're not going to lose
anything on time and we're still going
to be able to
get folks questions answered in the
interim then at least it continues
moving the ball forward
so i would think that would be
reasonable
the other reaction to the proposal to
change the date the effective date and
create a study committee
this legislation will actually do what
it's designed to do
without causing any distress to the
representative bernardi is recognized in
principle i think it's a it's a good
idea
the day change allows us time to uh
to have the study committee to truly
understand if we need to make further
tweaks
representative harrington is recognized
i'll make a quick ditto
that's great uh representative um
pimentel is recognized for clarification
the date change
was only uh for
part four is that correct
representative uh samsung is recognized
uh yes thank you mr chairman i i also
agree i think this is a good solution to
to delay the the date um
uh to a period of time where we can
uh have a study committee look at these
questions and be able to clarify some so
i think that's a good solution you know
okay representative partial is
recognized
yes uh you were asked you were
discussing earlier about
us being i'm forgive the term in
concordance for the senate
on this particular bill that's the
decision you you need to make
of course this would affect that uh
agreement would it not
now that that was a different bill oh
okay i thought it was a squad i do
apologize but i
i'm all wholeheartedly feeling the same
way then we should
go ahead with the study committee okay
i'm i'm not sure about how
we're proceeding it's been suggested
that you're only talking about a study
committee for part four
i thought we were talking about a study
committee to examine the issues raised
in the bill because
i don't think there was all that much
confusion about section four
i thought that we spent most of the day
talking about section one
and that's the part that has more to do
with the um the puc
proceeding that so my
i'm not sure that my comments were
germane to
the discussion if we're simply talking
you are correct we are discussing
section four
and what we specifically are discussing
is whether or not we should change the
effective date
of this section of the bill just part
four
uh to a year from now or 18 months from
now
[Music]
and then append to the legislation the
creation of a study committee
to study the issue but
really writing a report by the the 18th
of november
and uh that would allow us to to
submit subsequent legislation if it was
necessary
i don't believe we had real difficulty
with understanding section four i think
the difficulty
and that you know people are running the
two together and
that difficulty in understanding the
compensation mechanisms in section one
section four is really quite
straightforward
i'm not sure the two are particularly
that's one of the problems with omnibus
bills you get
parts to them that are sort of related
but not directly related
and so that that leads to confusion but
to to answer your questions specifically
yes i think there
are questions about how this would work
that the legislation doesn't make clear
and many of us still have questions
about how this would actually work
so that's why we that's why we're
struggling with it at this point uh
representatives why the study committee
would make sense
exactly exactly that's why we're
debating whether to do a study committee
or not
right but is it section one and four or
is it simply
section four because i said i think
we've allowed our difficulties
in one area to bleed over into the other
area and
where we where we really need a study
committee
it seems to me where there are issues
that people don't seem to understand and
where it is complicated
are in a different section but that's
enough
yes we're talking specifically about
adding a study committee
for section four only representative
mcgee yes thank you mr chair
and that was back to my question of what
were the questions because
you know that was what i wanted
clarification on because i don't i have
written
uh notes on the original part four for
questions that came up at the time like
a dividing line between distribution and
transmission was something
that was brought up avoided transmission
costs or
cost shifts were brought up but i
i didn't think any of those were
many of those are the reason that the
bill says that the commission shall
initiate rulemaking
because they can't be known before
they're known
and so it's a cart before the horse
thing again and i would just
that's why i want to know what questions
are we trying to satisfy with the study
committee because it doesn't seem to me
like there's
much question beyond that it's just that
those questions will have to come
after the legislation is passed in an in
another
agency that's tasked with that so i
that's what that's what my question was
is what what are the open questions
that we're trying to resolve by not
letting it go forward as it
as it's written okay good question
i will send you a written summary of the
questions that we discussed
before you arrive
[Music]
your hand is still up do you have
no forgot again i'll take it down
representative oxenoum your hand is
still up you have another question
yes i do thank you very much mr chair i
i really do
think it's too bad the cat wasn't here
but i think that she would be saying the
very same thing now if she had been here
all morning
what is it that is the problem because
it's and i think we all we all need to
understand that and and having a
discussion offline
doesn't help us in this work session to
get to the point
of saying how we want to proceed which
is
you know the work that we're here to do
so are you asking me to to re-ask the
questions i asked earlier
if if you would sir i think it would be
helpful to all of us
okay the questions i asked earlier
included
a limited producer shall receive credit
for actual avoided transmission charges
credit from whom that's
question number one uh question number
two
the transmission and distribution grids
are so tightly integrated
what's transmission versus distribution
can the two really be segregated
are there in fact avoided costs
and there was a fourth question that i
know
off the top of my head that i can go
back and look at the
recording again to refresh my memory but
those are the kinds of questions that i
think
a study committee committee needs to ask
and get concrete answers for
actually i think those are pretty
straightforward questions and
we might actually be able to get mr bilo
to answer them
for us well he did attempt to answer
them
but i'm not entirely satisfied with
those answers and i think i'm
get another perspective
[Music]
representative of can transmission and
distribution costs be segregated
they are all the time i mean that's
that's why one's called transmission
costs what's called distribution costs
you know i mean the puc and the iso
and you know that that's that's an issue
again not for the legislature that's not
a policy issue that's that's for those
who deal with the technical details
and they do it all the time they're
they're perfectly competent to do that
in in terms of who should receive the
credit i think that's
something that someone on this call must
know i i would assume it's the puc
but maybe it's iso but it's again that's
an issue a technical issue
that would be worked out by the the
do that um and then
are there in fact avoiding costs
i mean we have a situation where iso
rewards people for avoided costs you
know that that's that's monetized that's
that's being done again this this is
something that the the technical people
who handle these issues
they do this i i don't think this is a
reason
not to proceed with what we found in in
our last discussion to be
a very positive build that should that
should be moving
forward and that there are many you know
we have a renewable energy industry in
this state we
we have produced we have people engaged
in this who are standing by
waiting for the legislation to enable
them to go forward
and for us to say gee i don't know if we
can just distinguish that
we don't need to what but i do think we
can just
simply have to say that we trust the
competence of the agencies
that make these decisions for us that's
that's why the puc is there that's
why would they have their proceedings
and their staff and work out the details
and
my god thank god they do but again i
don't see
these things as as as holding up going
forward for the bill or needing to study
committee
okay thank you representative mckee
thank you mr chairman i i think that
that was a point that i i tried to make
earlier the other thing i was thinking
is from the nature of the questions
which i'm
thank you for providing them is that
when we had the presentation
on how renewable energy
economics works and to try and get some
of us further along in our
understanding of the pricing models and
the and the
the way things are working currently in
our energy economy
um when you talk about the credit for
avoided
i think it's not a credit like who pays
the credit
it's getting credit uh in other words
maybe paying a lower
rate because of the credit you're
bringing to the system
i think that's the complexity of
understanding it that we might not all
get
we might not all be experts on our
committee that understand
how that market is going to work but
that is that is what the rate setting
agency is going to determine they're
going to
they're going to determine whether any
costs are transferred
and um and my understanding is from the
presentation that we had
that the value of renewables coming on
to the distribution grid has been priced
and we had that in testimony
has been priced at much higher than the
rates that are currently being paid like
the default rate and that sort of thing
so
i think we have to trust that
um that there is a value to people
generating uh energy locally and
creating
additional resilience within the system
so that it's not
all dependent on one central location
that can be brought down just like that
cyber attack that we just saw that shuts
it down for everybody you know
there's a value and so um
the fact that we don't understand the
value i don't think should be an
inhibitor for us being able to allow
this portion of the bill
to go forward and that's the reason that
i asked the original question is because
i thought
section four was also straightforward
the only
questions that i heard put forth were
from eversource's attorney
matt fossum and the questions that he
asked were sort of
refuted by attorneys who work in
in uh in the ferc field you know after
the fact they basically said no that's
that's not the way it works and i think
cliff has said it
in testimony to us several times so
there's no uh concern for
limited electric energy producers coming
online and starting to function
helping people to produce energy where
they live
and trying to lower costs and trying to
manage peak demand and trying to
implement storage systems
that stuff is all good for new hampshire
that's not going to
it's not going to affect the
transmission grid because the energy
isn't going to be going
over the transmission lines and that was
the point that he was trying to make
he's like well i don't know that ferc
wouldn't be involved
and i think we got the answer that
that's not true that was the only
question that i saw
or heard and i didn't see the question
but the only question that i heard that
uh
made people go back and start scratching
their heads like is that something we
have to be concerned about and i believe
the answer after the fact was
it isn't it hasn't been an issue that's
why this bill keeps coming back
in front of us and that's i think why
the senate put
it forward as well to try and make sure
that it doesn't
lose another cycle so that's my spiel
okay thank you for your spiel
so i think we have a path forward then
for
prescript verify is an important
concept that many of us feel is is
justified here and a study committee i
think
could uh potentially give us the
verification
that we need that this proposed
legislation
can move forward so i think
what we'll do is we'll
add a study committee to the text of
part four
and we'll change the date on the
effective
change the effective date of the
legislation
uh 18 months or two months two years out
to give the study committee time to
provide the verification
that um what's contained in the
legislation
is actually implementable so we'll put
that all together and i'll have
a an amendment for everyone
i'll submit all this to ols tomorrow and
then as soon as
ols can act we'll have an amendment
for sb91 that contains
new language for part one
new language for part four it eliminates
uh part five altogether and as soon as
ols can
supply us with that um amendment i will
send it to everybody
and then we will plan on having an
executive session on the amendment
on either monday or tuesday of next week
and i'll also let you know about which
of those two days we'll be meeting
i think uh right now it looks like we
might be able to meet on monday so
from information i just received a
little while ago so
i'll keep you posted and in the meantime
i'll ask
representative callie pitts if she'd
so my comment is simply that i
understand
the the value in a study committee but
why not
just retain particu you know put an
another date on section 4 and do a
subcommittee so that we can bring it
back
asap because if you form a stud
excuse me uh no that's i i do not
understand why we wouldn't
defer to a study committee so that that
the people who are working on this now
who may not be here when you envision a
would be able to work on it and get it
that's all okay thank you for that
comment
uh anybody else have anything else they
need to add
we're almost at the lunch hour time to
adjourn the meeting uh representative
oxendine do you have a last comment
in just a second what was said that i
think a subcommittee
and let's let's get this thing in the
works and you know january 1
let's not be talking 18 months to two
years that's
completely unnecessary and it would
really be holding up
it would be a drag on the new hampshire
manufacturing on our renewable energy
and and it's not helping us get to any
of our goals
with the 10-year energy transition none
of them
representative man you get the last word
yeah i just have to say um
i envision in the future a pretty
complex system of many many many
components scattered all over the state
all over the region
and um i think we're going to need a
pretty good computer system to keep that
reliable
um we have to you know eventually we
will someday be
wondering about the um the
vulnerability of such a system
the uh that's a good topic a separate
topic but
yes it is a very separate topic less
vulnerable than one
centralized system that goes down with a
flick of the switch
okay so this is a productive work
session i thank you all for
uh your attendance i apologize that we
had to
reschedule the presentation on hb2
the department of energy but that was
out of our hands the senate um
took away our presenters basically by
forcing them to
do a presentation before the senate
finance committee so
we will reschedule that potentially for
next monday the 24th after we do our
exec sessions we'll have that
uh presentation from the governor's
staff
on the department of energy and hb2
so everybody have a wonderful week and a
wonderful weekend and we will see you
a uh a week from today i just wanted to
mention something
okay okay representative
quickly quickly oh yes thank you
um i just wanted to mention i wasn't
sure if anyone was aware with
representative
mann's comment that the statewide energy
data platform which is now called the
energy data hub
went to the public utilities commission
for a settlement hearing between the
utilities and all the stakeholders that
have been working on it for the last 17
months
and i was one of the interveners on that
so i got to sign the settlement
agreement
and uh they're in deliberations now but
um
they what we asked them for was approval
to submit an rfp
based on all the requirements that had
been defined during that process with a
lot of technical folks
and so we will actually have a tool
that will allow us to see what we cannot
see now for this energy that's coming
online because it's a very important
piece
to representative man's point of having
a dispersed and diverse energy system
you're going to have to have
some way to look at it and to do
planning and we don't have that today so
that's
that's what that project was all about
and i just wanted this group to know
that
um it's it's at least gotten out of the
gate with
a settlement with the utilities um which
was
hard fought and won okay
thank you very much all right with that
we will adjourn this meeting
and reconvene a week from today
uh keep an eye on your email inbox for
the exact meeting details thank you and
take care of you